franchement tellement vous si vous aviez
un gros problème ici autour de la cave
aux appels youri qui franchement vous
avez un énorme problème qui est qui et
qui nous avait plus d'argent ou de
crèmes de soin de tout pourquoi
problèmes d'argent vous appelleriez
avons à vous non mais les mecs quoi
savourer mais j'aimerais aussi un gros
problème ce serait qui toi honnêtement
si j'avais un gros gros problème je
crois je vous appelle merci maman et
vous savez que bien sûr je serai sur un
cas grave bien sûr vous savez que je
suis la divine prospère oseille une
balle benji où vous n'avez a dit alors
il a plein d'autres jeunes mais bien dit
non il avait non pas du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
photo vous pouvez appelez moi je
m'appelle madame arrêter avec ces
problèmes d'argent benzema problème même
si problème de coeur serait et et kiki
j'ai rappelé kelly à kelly s'est trahi
ses problèmes de coeur avec très fort
son ami franchement c'est une spécialité
je n'ai jamais appelé pour ça mais j'en
suis sûr jean-mathieu évidemment ah
ouais c'est mons avait prédit alors je
sais qu'il est prend un point quelle
heure il est très humain
je suis français n'y aura pourtant
devrait l'appeler alors l'année
prochaine
[Rires]
si je suis très famille genre appelé ma
mère marie je te parle ici que ces
jeunes ont capté monde entier nous tu me
vois moi tue beaulac ingénia jeu propre
et mong j'appelais mon nom mon staff en
tunisie fahid ben jaballah douce mais
qu'est ce qui selon vous fait votre
sérénité j'appelle toc un problème n'est
pas l'urgence il a un problème est un
problème on s'éclate et voilà c'est pas
aux doctes et apple qui tombent ou
chérie tu vois je sais me veut du mal tu
sais que tu es là pour toi mon bébé il
faut changer ce que je t'ai déjà lâché
sans déconner jamais jamais ah oui et
jamais mais lui sait qu'on est comme ça
comme ça va je vois ce que je sais déjà
tenues aussi voulait pas sortir merci ça
va aller à la civilité mathieu et puis
bon venu à l'est du muguet merci et
mettez le bien dans un vase
oui moi j'appelle lisa a wave elisa k ou
argent pourquoi est alors non mais la
paix lisa ça veut dire donc vous envoyer
un télégramme problème stop pigeon zappé
les à moi je comprends oui j'avoue que
j'avais bien s'appelle christian mais
aussi vous appeler toutes les deux
doubles ap
sa scène de christine rey d'isabelle non
plus ma vie moi qui vous happe l'équipe
prenne les coeurs j'appelle lulu et
problèmes d'argent rappelé christine
dans les infos sur elle ou la c1 qui a
pris les 3 millions du csa l'odeur est
ce que ça veut dire c'est ce qu'estime
sans argent des voix jude attention bon
on a des infos sur christine bah ouais
l'époque sombre et pèse quoi l ai pas
besoin
ah oui non c'est pas vrai débat alors
voulu pour acheter du muguet pour tout
le public
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai une mairie chétive à les rejoindre
il a voulu rappeler la regardez là les
couleurs melon en vidéo dans lequel elle
a regardé la breast melon on a enlevé
d'enlever les pépins fameux toit comme
un permis